welcome to our election 101 i'm vanessa
murphy and i'm david charns
if you aren't yet registered to vote you
can do it online or
in person before or on election day
if you register online now you will
still have to go and vote in person
so they can check your id if your
driver's license or id does not have
your current address
you can use a utility bill a bank
statement your car registration
a paycheck or any document issued by a
government
agency and to be clear if you are
already registered you do not have to
show
id at a polling place and once you get
your ballot you have three options
on how to vote you can do it in person
you can drop it off at any of those
in-person locations or you can drop it
in the mail
let's start with mail or drop-off to
fill out the double-sided ballot use
blue
or black ink and completely fill in the
oval
clark county registrar of voters joe
gloria says this is the longest ballot
clark county voters
have seen to return the ballot be sure
to sign it if you give the ballot to
someone else to return
for you you must fill out an
authorization
and it has to be postmarked by election
day
november 3rd now let's talk about
in-person voting we want to remind you
you can vote at any of the in-person
locations you don't have to go to a
specific one so it doesn't have to be
the one closest to you
early voting starts october 17th it ends
before
election day on october 30th now there
are 48 locations
in clark county the times vary though so
you want to check them first
and you have to follow some rules of
course we are living
in a pandemic so you should of course
review your
sample ballot before you head to the
poll you also want to wear a mask
and try to bring hand sanitizer or of
course wash your hands if you can
now you can also just drop off that
mail-in ballot at any of those
in-person locations we have a list of
those on the website and the video
the link that is is under this video in
clark county
ballots are scanned if a machine rejects
the signature due to significant and
multiple differences
and then if two election workers also
reject it
the registrar's office is advised to
contact the voter
the voter has the opportunity then to
make sure the ballot is then counted
by answering three personal questions
through the registrar on the phone
or using an app through the secretary of
state's office
and remember there are 48 early voting
sites throughout clark county
and 125 of those in-person sites but
that's just for election day
don't expect that we're going to get the
final results though
on november 3rd of course they have to
count in all these mail-in ballots they
have to wait for them to arrive
so it could be up to a week before
everything is counted and set in stone
eight news now is here to help you if we
didn't answer
any questions you may have please let us
know we'll continue to update you on air
and at eight newsnow dot com